[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much for joining us and let
us begin with our first and only story
the 2016 election or as you may know it
I thought I wanted it to be over but now
that it's over I wish it was still going
on because it turns out the ending is
even worse twenty 16 the results
Oh Tuesday what we're a little different
than what just over half the voters
wanted we can now project the winner the
presidential race CNN projects Donald
Trump wins the presidency Donald J Trump
will become the 45th President of the
United States it's true that happened it
turns out instead of showing our
daughters that they could someday be
president America proved that no grandpa
is too racists to become leader of the
free world look papa someday that could
be you now if you're like me the
implications of this have been hitting
you in waves one minute you're none and
the next minute you realize that Donald
Trump this man will soon have access to
the nuclear codes and then maybe you get
distracted by daily life until it hits
you again
o our future president was supported by
a former Grand Wizard of the Klan and 60
million people voted for him despite
that and then maybe you finally managed
to get some sleep but then you wake up
realizing oh the Supreme Court
because remember Merrick garland who the
Republicans have refused to confirm all
year you know the guy whom we asked you
to choose a Supreme Court dog for you
you actually picked this one by the way
what we never announced it because we
figured that we would tell you when he
was confirmed well he's not getting
confirmed and that dog is dead now look
actually not really she she is fine but
she's not getting on the court Donald
Trump will fill that seat and maybe more
Ruth Bader Ginsburg is in her aid
Anthony Kennedy is is over 80 and there
are other justices who've talked bandied
about the idea of retiring bottom line
Donald Trump is going to shape the
Supreme Court for decades to come
Wow that is one of those phrases you've
just assumed you would never have to
hear like vanilla rice is picking up his
Nobel Prize in Physics or Henry
Kissinger just came out with a line of
skinny jeans they go with everything now
it has been wave after wave of nausea
all week I woke up on Thursday feeling
fractionally better but then I turned on
the TV and saw Trump in the Oval Office
with President Obama and just look at
the president's face there he cannot
believe what he's looking at either in
fact just listen to the actual audio in
that room compact that is the new
national anthem now
you see we're laughing we're having fun
and then you remember Trump's going to
be in charge of the military and leaders
there do not know what to expect they
have seen Donald Trump's statements on
the campaign trail talking about
waterboarding talking about bombing with
little regard to civilian casualties
talking about taking the oil in Iraq all
of these things potentially very serious
violations of international law of
violations of the Geneva Convention
yes our president-elect has at various
times said he'd bomb civilians loot oil
and water board which isn't a military
strategy so much as the series of words
that Donald Rumsfeld mutters so he can
stay hard while he's masturbating and
look look
Trump won this election by which I mean
he won the electoral college which for
reasons I will never understand no
matter how many times it's explained to
me is how things are done and many
people it's important remember many
people are happy to see him in office
some are voters who think he'll bring
jobs back and shake up Washington others
are happy simply because he isn't
Hillary Clinton and others of course are
Vladimir Putin and Scott Baio
but for the rest of us we are faced with
these same questions as a guy that woke
up the day after a Vegas bachelor party
deep in the desert naked tied to a
cactus and a dead clown named Lee
how the did we get here and what
the do we do now because Donald
Trump will be president and respecting
democracy means accepting that although
there is one sentiment that I would
argue takes that a little too far the
man hasn't even been a president for a
day yet all right let's give him a
chance to be the president give Donald
Trump a chance we now have to give him a
chance and see how he's gonna govern the
American people should give him a chance
to government because if he succeeds we
succeed now in the broadest sense I get
that impulse hope for the best in the
face of very long odds it's like we're
on a plane and we just found out our
pilot is a wombat I don't like this I
don't understand how it happens
pretty sure we're headed for disaster
but what the hell come on batty prove me
wrong optimism optimism is nice if you
can swing it but you've got to be
careful because it can feed into the
normalization of Donald Trump and he is
not normal he is abnormal he's a human
what is wrong with this picture he
sticks out like a sore thumb and frankly
he even looks like a sore thumb so so
giving him a chance in the sense of not
speaking out immediately against
policies that he's proposed is dangerous
because some of them are alarming just
some of trumps promises repeal and
replace Obamacare build a wall along the
southern border with Mexico and get
Mexico to pay for said wall deport all
11 to 12 million undocumented immigrants
in this country including children
appoint a special prosecutor to
investigate and potentially jail Hillary
Clinton temporarily ban Muslims and
immigrants from terror prone nations
from coming into the United States okay
okay stop just stop because it sounds
like you're reading the to-do list on
Satan's refrigerator which of course
Satan no longer needs now that hell has
frozen over and while some are arguing
that Trump might not have meant all
those things that leaves us with two
devastating options either we just
elected a president who didn't mean a
single word he said or we elected one
who did and it's impossible to know
which one earlier tonight he did his
first major post-election interview and
he was asked about Obamacare which
remember he had labeled a disaster when
you replace it are you going to make
sure that people with preconditions are
still come yes because it happens to be
one of the strongest s you're gonna keep
also with the children living with their
parents for an extended period within it
you're gonna keep much try and keep that
oh okay
so get ready for a barely changed
version of Obamacare called Trump care
which sounds like a health care plan
where doctors feel your breasts for
lumps whether you ask them to or not
by the way don't get complacent that
he's going to keep those aspects of
Obamacare he might change his mind on
that again Trump is like a magic 8-ball
every time you shake him he gives you a
different answer and sometimes the
answer is just big-league or that's
somebody on my daughter right
so so we have to take all of trumps
promises seriously and the truth is they
were not all universally bad for
instance he ran on a promise to drain
the swamp cracking down on corruption
and ending the reign of Washington
insiders which sounds great so let's try
and be positive for a moment what are
the early signs on that some of the
potential cabinet members that are being
reported by CNN that are under
consideration Rudy Giuliani Newt
Gingrich chris Christie Reince Priebus
right so that's the longtime head of the
RNC a former speaker who entered
Congress in 1979 a former mayor turned
professional and a man whose
name is synonymous with scandal who's
under rides that is so swampy
you're going to need to swap out Air
Force One for one of those shallow
bottom boats with a big fan on the back
and the thing is it actually makes sense
for Trump to appoint people with
significant experience in government
until a few days ago the highest office
he'd ever held was on the 26th floor of
a shitty building on Fifth Avenue but
some of the people he's bringing in are
horrifying his transition team includes
people like Ken Blackwell who has argued
that homosexuality is a choice and he's
named Myron Ebell to lead his EPA
transition team making him a frontrunner
for administrator
despite this the whole case for global
warming I believe is silly
and I believe the vast majority of
scientists think it's silly and
therefore I'm a little bit embarrassed
that I waste my time on a silly issue
okay well just first of all the vast
majority of scientists believe humans
are contributing to climate change and
secondly this man does not have a
science degree he wouldn't even be
qualified to head the agency of baking
soda volcanoes
so how the did we get here well
clearly there are many possible answers
to that question
including misleading forecasts that bred
complacency a flawed candidate who
failed to appeal to white rule and
working-class voters and and this is
worth repeating deep racism and/or
indifference to it and for those
including us who were shocked by Tuesday
we're gonna be examining all of these
four years but for tonight let's look at
just one narrow element that may have
helped bring us here because it will be
important going forward and that is on
media specifically how a system that is
supposed to catch a serial liar failed
and I'm not just referring to mainstream
TV news although some did wait far too
long to take Trump seriously giving him
billions of dollars worth of free media
at CNN for instance sometimes ran his
speeches almost in their entirety and
their president Jeff Zucker now admits
that might not have been such a great
idea I'd say that if we made a mistake
last year it's that we probably did put
on too many of his campaign rallies in
the in those early months you know
unedited and just let them run and I
think in hindsight we probably shouldn't
have done that as much yeah it turns out
hindsight much like the year we're all
now desperately looking forward to is
2020 and that is that is not to say that
there wasn't some great coverage of
Trump in this election from outlets like
the Washington Post and The New York
Times even CNN
eventually pivoted and began correcting
Trump in lower-third graphics such as
Trump I never said Japan should have
nukes parentheses he did and that is
good journalism if I gave a speech
saying on the sexiest man alive it would
be fair to tag that with parentheses
look at him now that's that's a mean
joke to laugh at but the problem is
the problem is the impact of Corrections
like that which may have sunk a
candidate in another era was compromised
because there is no longer a consensus
of what a fact is trust in mainstream
media outlets has been falling and
people can choose to get their news from
echo chambers that validate their views
and there is nothing inherently wrong
with media that has a viewpoint this
show has a viewpoint we fact check
everything we say but I don't pretend to
be neutral on things like criminal
justice reform and for it coldplay I'm
against it
or dEWALT's ladders they're a seamless
blend of style and performance walking
up one is like ascending to heaven on a
golden cloud I'm not being paid to say
that I'm just a fan but a healthy media
diet has to be broader than that and
unfortunately the way that many of us
can see news now is micro-targeted the
majority of Americans 62 percent say
they get their news from social media
according to Pew Research 44 percent of
all adults say they get news
specifically from Facebook that's true
news is now one of the three things that
we get from social media the other two
being our entire sense of self-worth and
pictures of shaved alpacas and and fake
facts circulate on social media to a
frightening extent you may have seen
this quote from Donald Trump online
about Republicans being dumb he never
said that
it's not true just as it's not true that
the Pope endorsed Trump because of
course he didn't but that story was
shared almost a million times which is
absurd everybody knows the candidate the
Pope endorsed was Joe exotic they have
very similar views on deregulating Tiger
preserves please share this news a
million times but there is now a whole
cottage industry specializing in
hyper-partisan sometimes wildly
distorted clickbait at BuzzFeed news
research sites like addicting info on
the left and a freedom daily on the
right both of which have over a million
followers on Facebook putting them in
the same range as Anderson Cooper 360
and found that some of them were
publishing many viral articles
containing flat-out falsehoods over two
weeks 38% of news on some
republican-leaning Facebook pages was
part
li or completely false compared to 19
percent of news shared on some Democrat
leaning Facebook pages yeah and before
you say well Republicans are twice as
bad
19 percent is still terrible and it is
not news that there is misinformation on
Facebook just look at the relationship
status it's complicated the accurate
version of that will clearly be in three
weeks I'll be single but I can't admit
it yet
but these sites can warp your views
pretty fast your newsfeed may have been
full of the times and the post stories
about Donald Trump's actual scandals but
many Americans logged onto Facebook
every day and saw like this and
this cesspool of nonsense would be a
problem anyway were it not for the fact
that one of the people in thrall to it
is our future president back in March he
claimed that a man who had rushed the
stage at one of his rallies had ties to
Isis something that had circulated
online and had been found to be untrue
and when that was pointed out to him
this was his response there's no ties to
Isis for this man no law-enforcement
official and this video that you link to
appears to be a hoax what do I know
about it all I know is what's on the
Internet
okay okay okay he's easily being on the
Internet is not a high bar for accuracy
if I edited Wikipedia to say that Dianne
Wiest sri lamb is Diane frosted
mini-wheats our next president would
believe that to be true in fact during
the campaign Trump routinely used his
platform to share wildly incorrect
information and even fellow
conservatives try to point out how
respond irresponsible this was you
tweeted out that White's killed by
blacks user statistics you picked up
from somewhere at a rate of 81% and
that's totally wrong
White's killed by blacks is 15% hey Bill
bill am I going to check every statistic
I get millions and millions of people
who died and a presidential continued
directions of people you know what fine
but this came out of radio shows and
everything else
okay okay okay okay okay I'm got it from
radio is maybe do weirdest nonsense
explanation I've ever heard it's like if
someone said this sandwich tastes weird
and you said but I found it in a hole if
there's something wrong with it then
what was it doing sitting in our hole
and that is the evil genius at working
weird conspiracy has always
been bubbling under the surface but
Trump was the first major candidate to
harness and fully legitimize it and it's
obvious in hindsight he came along and
told millions of people every crazy
email you've ever forwarded was true and
that at least in part is why he will be
our next president and to their credit
some Republican lawmakers were calling
him out on this during the campaign I'm
gonna tell you what I really think of
Donald Trump this man is a pathological
liar he doesn't know the difference
between truth and lies he was right he
was just right but before you think
Republicans might now stand up to Trump
I will remind you that by the end of the
campaign Ted Cruz like many others not
only said he vote for Trump but was
doing this hi this is Ted Cruz y'all I
was calling encourage you to come out
and vote like him
wow that is hard to watch this is Ted
Cruz just calling to remind you to vote
for a man who insulted my wife and said
my dad helped kill JFK any way at life
has no meaning thank you I want to die
take care now God is dead move on
goodbye now goodbye so there is very
little holding Trump back and remember
in January he will be sworn into office
and there is another wave of nausea for
you it hits you in small ways and large
doesn't it for instance had you
considered the fact that portraits of
Trump are going to be hanging in our
airports or that the man who disparaged
a gold star family will now be expected
to comfort the families of fallen
soldiers and maybe you tried to make
yourself feel better
fantasizing that he might Google how
much does the president get paid get
depressed and then resign but that is
when you remember Mike pence who
might be even worse because he looks
like he's from the 1950s but he thinks
like he's from the 1650s what's that you
say her pregnancy was terminated before
birth well clearly she's a witch hold a
funeral for the fetus and throw the
mother in a lake and I know this is all
depressing but it does bring us back to
the important question what the do
we do now
and for the record the answer is not
moved to Canada literally the only
excuse to ever migrated to Canada is if
you were born there originally it's
springtime and you are a goose that's it
that is it no instead here we're gonna
need to stay here and fight and not just
politically in four years when he's up
for reelection but constantly monitoring
legislation as it moves through Congress
and voting when your legislators
come up for re-election in two years but
that is still below the barest minimum
of what is going to be needed because
for the last eight years we've had a
president we could assume would
generally stand up for the rights of all
Americans but that is going to change
now so we're going to have to actively
stand up for one another and it can't be
just sounding off on the internet or
sharing think pieces or videos like this
one that echo around your bubble I'm
talking about actual sacrifice to
support people who are now under threat
so if you can afford the time or money
support organization
that are going to need help under a
trump administration for instance if
you're concerned about women's health
donate to Planned Parenthood or the
center for reproductive rights if you
don't believe man-made global warming is
a silly issue donate to the National
Resources Defense Council
if you don't think refugees are a
terrorist army in disguise donate to the
international refugee assistance project
oh and also given these guys track
record I would also recommend donations
to the n-double-a-cp Legal Defense Fund
The Trevor Project for LGBTQ youth and
the Mexican American Legal Defense and
Educational Fund would be perfect of
your compassion for Latinos those
Beyonce I don't know occasionally eating
a taco bowl and and you check
the box for recurring donations if you
can because this is not a short-term
problem and also just for a - I'll give
you just a dash of fun here I will point
out if you have relatives who supported
Trump you can give money in their name
so consider your holiday shopping this
year done Happy Holidays Nana The Trevor
Project thanks you
that I would single out for help here
and that is the press because as we've
seen Trump is a masterful denier of both
reality and responsibility he's a man
who would kick you in the nuts and then
tell you that your penis did it so the
press is going to face challenges not
just because Trump's chief strategist is
Steve banning of Breitbart news but also
because of yet another promise that
Trump made if I become president oh do
they have problems they're gonna have
such product I'm gonna open up our libel
laws so when they write purposely
negative and horrible and false articles
we can sue them and win lots of money
we're gonna open up those libel laws
okay well first there is no federal
libel law for Trump to open up and as
many supposed recipients of Trump's
charitable gifts might tell you you
can't open something up if it doesn't
exist but but that attitude of punishing
the press is genuinely worrisome now
that he is going to be President so
instead of sharing parties and means you
found on Republic goofs dot redneck and
Democrat peacock you need to support
actual journalism by buying a
subscription to outlets like The Times
or the post or your local newspaper or
donating to groups like Pro Publica a
nonprofit which does great investigative
journalism
what is if we don't get actively
involved to at least mitigate Trump's
damage things will not be okay
and yes the Sun will rise each day but
the continuing rotation of the earth
should not be your baseline expectation
of American society and I just need to
ask you one more thing it is going to be
too easy for things to start feeling
normal especially if you are someone who
is not directly impacted by his actions
so keep reminding yourself this is not
normal write it on a post-it note and
stick it on your refrigerator
hire a skywriter once a month tattoo it
on your arse because a clan backed
misogynist internet troll is going to be
delivering the next State of the Union
address and that is not normal it is
up and the only thing that gives
me one degree of comfort is that I think
part of Trump might be realizing that
now to just look at his face
after meeting with Paul Ryan and getting
a glimpse of what this job actually
entails here is the genuine audio from
that moment
[Music]
[Applause]
I feel the same look I don't know what
happens from here and this is actually
our final show of the year
and normally on our last show we mash up
elements from the season and we dance
around in the studio but that doesn't
really seem appropriate tonight not just
because of the election but because 2016
has been an uncommonly shitty year from
the ongoing crisis in Syria to Zika to
Ryan Lochte being a douche to a
seemingly endless string of celebrity
deaths including just this week Leonard
Cohen so we have put something together
about how awful this year has been we
started it a little while ago but it now
feels more prescient than ever because
even though this year still has seven
weeks left I'm calling it early 2016 has
been the worst so thank you for
watching and please enjoy this tribute
to a truly terrible year let's face it
2016 has been one calamity after another
and while it will be remembered for the
giant calamity we all just witnessed we
shouldn't lose sight of the other
multiple ways this has been a shitty
year we could have loosed 2016 off the
calendar the perfect good with me pretty
rotten year I think most people would
would admit that it totally blew your
novel this world is feeling scarier it's
feeling a little colder for EU it was a
really crap year
the whole breaks it was kind of a mess
just a lot of like hatred to a lot of
groups I think I think that's like been
the staple of this year Syrian refugee
crisis
lots of sexism being very blatant I
think it's absolutely disgusting what
the city of flint did to to his
residents the New York Jets suck the
Yankees missed the playoffs I mean like
Kevin Durant going to UM go on a coma
state that was a move some
so am i watching Miami I got
broken up with and I was pretty sure I
had a girlfriend three half years she
broke down feet about two months ago my
landlords piece of I met Bruce
Willis here like we've got one two
asking for picture and he said no so
that made me feel bad my son is hitting
puberty and he's being a real pain in
the ass
I got a old mole divided over my
birthday so I was like a cherry on top
of like a shitty year menopause never
forget Harambee rom bees out there
listening he took shots for us we should
take shots for him too many deaths Brits
Kris my man
hi miss Prince Prince I mean that was
just I think the worst is that impose
death David Bowie when the by Bowie
that was my big one five dog man come on
man shoutout to the q-tip man Tribe
Called Quest I grew up on that I mean
that was one of the biggest what he
represents for black people in America
that's a huge deal for me Oh Mike a
butterfly sting like a bee
Oh God Gene Wilder Alan Rickman
Snape dude oh dear did suck 2016
year 2016 you 2016 14 15
you 2016 bad year year 2016 this
for you 2016 the Lord but
2016 I'm Donald Trump 2016 CNN
won't let me say this musi but get
2016 4 2016
my school is missing where's this
mayonnaise 2016 15 2016 2016
a 2016 haha 2016 falls below my
standards of quality for 2016
you 2016 8 2016 go punch yourself
me dick up this year
you 2016 15 2016 4 future Oliver a
2016 you in mid 2017 you too I
hate you already you 2016
you're asking me 2016 2015 2016
from the bottom of my heart go
yourself you 2016 you
[Music]
that's our show and so much for watching
let's all try harder next year good
night
[Applause]